ever since DQ me my prosthetics all I
ever wanted to do with around my name is
James Lozano and I'm from New York I was
eight months old when they amputated me
so James was born with a rare congenital
deformity where basically he lacked an
ankle when he was born when we Doris a
sec um porque uno como Padre Louella lo
que esta pasando con su hijo pero en ta
please nama gracias por que fue lo mejor
que podemos hacer we really feel
fortunate to have a patient like James
who will come in at short notice meet a
new family and discuss a lot of the
questions they have about what to expect
living your life with artificial Lakes
my motto has always been don't live life
with limitations I never felt that my
prosthetics got in the way of anything
he's one of those patients who always
comes in with the Mets Jersey on I love
the Mets I've always been a Mets fan and
my favorite players David Wright and I
would Christ and that's won the World
Series
my tour well I'm actually looking
forward to like exploring all of it
because I've gone to City fields a bunch
of times but I've available nice at like
at the top top
oh I have a David very science Jersey
for you wow thank you
what do you think wow you like it yeah
man that's cool it's cool Jersey what's
going on I do it I'm David nice to meet
you
pleasures all mine thanks for making it
out thank you it's good to finally meet
you thank you and I see like the Jersey
I love it
the bleacher poor guys did that so you
can thank them for that I got you a bat
and some batting gloves thank you
here's that now they say you go around
and talk to kids and you know get them
motivated and that's cool that's very
cool
Austin you do that whenever I needed the
hospital just calls up for any patient
I just go I bet the kids appreciate that
yeah let's go walk around watch these
guys hit you wanna go
what you guys want to do field yours
James might be too shy to tell you what
he is he'll train without running the
bases running a basis I'm gonna run a
basis
James was also you know in just his
energy who knows his tenacity you know
he just has this desire to accomplish
things my favorite part about today you
know other than you know the the
inspirational story and what James is
doing to help other kids is you know
we're running the bases and he slipped
on third base fell down and he didn't
want my help getting back up you know he
got back up and wanted to finish and
cross home plate on his own and for him
to have the attitude that he has and you
know do what he does on a daily basis is
also a tear in Kanazawa normally yes I
mean you can always pin also seen
telehealth a locatable mucho e some on
mortgages are they they love eating so
he was into the comic books and
superheroes so he's got his a superhero
legs on it's only fitting you know
because he's got a superhero mentality
one of my co-workers called me up and
said you know there was a young guy here
with prosthetic legs yeah you may want
to talk to him just recently my son's
been in the Cox and he lost both his
legs it's hard and you know he told me
just the other day that he can't see his
future anymore I always say that keep
always look forward to your future in it
to see him smiling and happy and
enjoying life and offering that to other
people I think it's the greatest thing
whenever you're available I I think
you're hero for doing things like that I
appreciate a man thank you for the time
all right thank you my let me thank you
it's okay I'm only one person on this
earth out of seven billion so it's a
really big pleasure to help anyone don't
look into your past look forward look
into your future and what you would
become nothing's for sure
just keep looking for